let's meet
some of the cast as uh seegers mr rob
riggle
come on out rob
as poopa
keegan michael key
as josie in the film nina dubrev
and he plays justin in the film mr damon
wayans jr
welcome guys i did get to see let's be
cops last week and i got to tell you
laughed my ass off oh good cool man oh
good good let me see it's a good that's
a really good thing
it's about a friendship it's about it's
about your character damon and jake
johnson also from new girl who plays
your buddy in this film
and the relationship you guys have as
friends and as friends do you sometimes
are there for each other sometimes you
want to punch each other in the head
absolutely and sadly jake could not be
with us today he wanted to be but he's
busy working on another project however
he did send along a little piece of tape
uh he wanted us to play here for you
guys so here's a little something from
one of the stars of let's be cops mr
jake johnson oh he invested he told me
that he he told me he made this and he
said he literally made it just to make
us laugh
and he accomplished that it worked
i'm assuming you guys were busting up a
lot on the set of this film absolutely
it was it was a good time one of the
reasons why i even did the movie is
because i heard jake uh might do it so
we called each other i was like i'll do
it if you do it and then um
we did it and we we petitioned for rob
to be on it because we both love rob uh
when we found out keegan was doing it we
were like oh my god and nina yeah they
almost all signed off as soon as they
found out that i was doing it
but it was it was just great it was
great to uh be with so many funny people
with uh with really great energy and
nobody had egos everybody was just ready
to make the best uh product they could
make
and uh the writer director who could be
with us today uh luke greenfield
he is a very funny guy and from what i
understand this is based on a true story
this was a guy who actually put on a cop
uniform and
pretended to be a cop largely to pick up
women but also to screw with people
absolutely that's that's what that's
what um
started this movie i guess yeah it was
the uh the genesis
was him uh and his co-writer uh nikki
thomas they dressed up uh as cops they
actually went up got they got they got
arrested too they got arrested
they got let right out though because
i mean i couldn't do it he couldn't do
that
if we tried to do the same thing he did
we would be unbelievable they put us
under the gym absolutely yeah oh yeah
definitely
but before we talk any more about it
let's take a look at some
very funny footage from let's be cops
he's just laughing as you can see it's a
serious drama
yes
uh that lady actually improvised that
line by the way
yeah that just came out of her and we
were in the video village dying like
that's for sure getting in the movie
they're telling me that i'm out of time
already guys i'm sorry but i i insist
that we get one good story from each of
you about making the film this one funny
story about what happened start down
there
damon
uh one good story about making the film
um
there was this uh that senior that scene
in um the hardware store where the guy
is like on my face yes
uh in the actual movie
he doesn't have any underwear on
there's no thong in the room and uh
he
gets he tries to get away but he like
slides up my face
i saw everything
like everything like that
i'll jump in on that too because that
was one of my favorite parts of the
movie because the reason he slides up
damon's face is because jake and i are
pulling him up that way
it's terrible terrible
nina i saw out of his mouth like that's
like
through him right through nina um
it's hard to remember i mean like it's
let's let's be real it's the boys movie
i mean it's
i'm just the girl so i wasn't there for
as much of it i think that
the behind the scenes everything they
would say
there wasn't a second that went that
went by that they weren't
doing something stupid yeah i mean
stupid like i've been trying to forget
it
is one of my new favorite characters of
all time he is pretty brilliant he likes
bluebells yeah i do like i like me
we spent a good deal of time you know
because
poop is a drug deal he's a dominican
drug dealer and so i was like working on
this accent that he will be using for
the entire film you know
all the time yeah that's exactly what
happened
people you can't understand what i'm
saying to you
can you not understand what i'm saying
to you
what i'm saying you are you saying are
you saying
you're saying jew or you're saying no
i'm talking talking about me and talking
about you oh you me oh i'm talking about
it no i mean now now that i broke it
down but
but the first scene that we shot i was
doing that and and damon and jake they
must have asked for 10 minutes we did
like a 15-minute take 10 minutes where
they're going buddy i cannot understand
what you said
in character but
we did we have a scene where i'm
strapped to an ironing board
with cellophane
and they waterboard me to uh
they try to get my head into the sink to
waterboard me and so
we're doing the take and everything's
kind of going and every apparently i
just found out from aditya adichia is
one of our uh one of our producers he
was like this looks good so it's good it
looks like it's really getting
waterboarded
and then there's cut and they're like
kid you're good
uh no yeah no uh
yeah they're actually they're
waterboarding me so
he was shaking he was going into shock
and we had no idea we were all like
having fun like ah because he stayed in
the character i was like i would have
yelled cut i'm dying
but i thought like for somehow i thought
it wasn't happening to me because well
they don't have a towel over my face or
anything so that can't be it you can't
die on the side no am i is this
something this can't be suffocation
i can't i couldn't be charged right now
with all these cameras around here
that was
so that was hilarious that was funny
yeah
and uh rob
seeger's is for me like the hero of the
movie he is what a great role he's doing
a great job with it
uh yeah no it's the first uh like
straight role i've played uh ever
normally i'm a big douchebag
seekers is not an idiot no he's not he's
he plays it straight uh and uh that's
what kind of appealed to me i you know
getting to work with with my friends
obviously is was the number one reason i
wanted to do this movie but a chance to
to play a sincere
honest character with some heroic
qualities that just
really appealed to me so i wanted to do
it more like the real you right robert
come on that's what we're talking about
right
that's the real wriggle
you